[Música]
hola gracias por continuar en la
pantalla de france 24 es hora de nuestra
sección 5 minutos con y hoy nos acompaña
alfredo celis él es presidente del
comité de vigilancia ética del colegio
médico de perú con el vamos a dialogar
sobre las condiciones en las que
trabajan quienes integran el sector
sanitario del país en esta pandemia de
coronavirus kobe 19 un tema que ha
generado quejas y también denuncias por
parte de trabajadores de la salud
peruanos
el señor seguir muchísimas gracias por
estar presente en france 24 cuéntenos en
qué condiciones se encuentra no el
sistema de salud peruano ya a seis meses
de pandemia
bueno desde antes de la pandemia la
situación en el sistema de salud de
nuestro país era bastante precaria con
déficit en camas déficit en hospitales
hasta el momento hay más de 100
ahora sí estamos teniendo problemas de
comunicación no sé si en estos momentos
está con nosotros doctor félix nos está
escuchando
si retomamos por favor porque se
interrumpió la comunicación hablábamos
del estado de situación del sector
sanitario de perú pero usted hacía
referencia a cómo estaba previo a la
pandemia verdad
si les decía que ya previó la pandemia
era muy precario con un difícil número
de camas un terrible en el número de
hospitales y un déficit grande en el
número de camas uci lo cual es motivado
que muchas de la población y atendemos
más de 720.000 contagiados y en el
sector médico tenemos más de 160 médicos
fallecidos más de 2.000 infectados y
como 300 en las unidades cuidados
intensivos ahora trabajadores no del
sector sanitario de perú han realizado
muchísimas protestas por los recursos
por los salarios entre otras demandas
han obtenido algún tipo de respuesta por
parte de las autoridades
la respuesta por parte del ministerio de
salud ha sido limitada en el caso de los
médicos y los médicos nombrados que son
los menos los médicos del sistema
cupcakes un sistema de contrato que se
va renovando cada seis meses y un
sistema que se llama de contratación por
terceros que es bastante precario donde
no tienen gratificaciones donde no
tienen vacaciones donde no tienen seguro
médico y su estado de estabilidad
laboral es mínimo
y qué efectos tuvieron y tienen no
todavía estas condiciones en la calidad
de atención a los pacientes afecta a
esto
si bien es cierto el ministerio de hecho
muchos esfuerzos por mejorar en cuanto a
la capacidad resolutiva de las camas sus
y de las camas en los hospitales en
cuanto al tipo de reconocimiento al
trabajo de los médicos esto ha sido muy
lento en realidad por eso se han habido
protestas y paros para tratar de que se
cumpla lo que se ha ofrecido como que
todos los médicos del sistema que pasen
a ser nombrados y los sistemas de
contratación por terceros no quede
ninguna parte en el sistema cas que sin
ser bueno es mejor que el sistema de
terceros se ofreció a pagar a las
guardias y muchos de éstos
no han sido cumplido porque el
ministerio ha tenido limitaciones en
poder ejecutar lo que había ofrecido
ahora señor félix en lo que es el mapa
global no de el coronavirus kobe 19 pero
representa un caso particular y que para
muchos es bastante alarmante porque con
cerca de 32 millones de habitantes tiene
algo más de 30.000 muertos por el virus
del cob y 19 lo que lo convierte en el
país con la tasa de mortalidad más alta
del mundo para usted cómo se explica
esta situación
la explicación se explica que si bien es
cierto se tomó medidas que fue afectadas
por toda la población en un inicio este
esta no se cumplió con el correr del
tiempo la 40 de presentada que fue
acatada por de 100 por ciento de la
población al inicio no se pudo mantener
en el tiempo porque hay una gran parte
de la población para el cual era
imposible quedarse en casa porque tenía
que salir a obtener los medios para
poder dar de comer a sus hijos entonces
la cuarentena que hace levantó de facto
la población la levantó mucho antes que
él el gobierno lo haya hecho todas las
características de precariedad y la
inequidad y de seguridad de la sociedad
esta cuarentena pudo ser cumplida por un
sector de la población pero por un
sector mayoritario él no pudo de la vida
y salvar las calles y si efectos
alfredo series muchisimas gracias por su
presencia en france mit y 4 en nuestra
audiencia como siempre le decimos que
sigan cuidándose mucho continúen
informando se en france 24